foreign
[Music]
specific vulnerability to dramatic pain
injury
I'm Alex martirocian from the laboratory
of Lia biology at Center of brain and
disease research located in the IDK
lowering in Belgium and this work we are
doing in collaboration with the
University of Amsterdam and the
bioinformatics cro
but before going on with the main topic
of my talk I would like to give you a
brief introduction on Cell identities
and the principal dogma of molecular
biology
as we know in our organism all the cells
are differentiated from stem cells
but they get different identity during
their maturation and they are located in
different organs and perform totally
different functions
how different muscle cells and
nervousness could be you can imagine
um so what is making these cells
different
point to the principal dogma of
molecular biology they have all the
different cell types with different
morphologies and they are sharing the
same DNA what is different what is
making different Vistas
is there nrna content which is
transcribed from their DNA so only a
specific set of mRNA is transcribed in
every cell type and they are
synthetizing or trans being translated
to different types of proteins
and these two steps are making cells
very different these are the proteins
that are performing different functions
in the cells they allow them to interact
with each other they are defining their
shape and so on so the main difference
is coming from the MRNA content in
various sentence
so what is revolution in the Bible about
recent Technologies single cells
aspectomies Technologies is that now
nowadays they are able to
quantify the whole transcriptome in a
single cell
this is giving lots of advantages and
the principal Advantage is that you can
quantify transcriptomic changes
uh in case of injury and disease
something that has not been possible
before and nowadays they are doing this
as a single cell resolution which is of
course giving us an information about
the functional molecular Pathways in a
very cell type specific manner so we
know in which cell types which Pathways
have been uttered in the case of an
injury or disease and therefore we can
design a very effective Therapeutics
that is targeting given cell types
so this revolutionary Technologies
came in use
approximately 10 years ago and now
there's revolutionizing the biomedical
research
in this particular talk I would like to
tell you how did we use this
to understand molecular changes
happening in the brain after dramatic
brain injury
the traffic brain injury is caused by an
external Force which is affecting our
brain function
and it is a major Global Health concern
it is affecting approximately 69 million
people per year and they are all
vulnerable to that traumatic brain
injury can occur
in situations like polling traffic
accidents and so on
impacting on people all around the world
so of course the first cell types that
we want to look at in this case are
neurons which are the building blocks of
our new of our brain and in the brain
there are different types of neurons and
they interact with each other
by transferring signal from one to other
and creating a network of communication
thanks to this neural network we are
able to think recent memorize events and
so on
however neurons are not the only cell
types in the brain they are also
gliastas
says that my laboratory is focusing on
and in particular they are studying
exercise so in this presentation I am
going to focus on exercise alone however
there are other clear cell types in the
brain
so exercise are star-shaped cells as you
can see on this slide and they are known
to support neuronal functions
neurogenesis
and they are helping neurons to develop
and they support new one to neuron
Communications at the signups
so what is happening to these cell types
after injury neurons can be damaged
or lost
so they are not able to perform their
normal functions anymore
and this is of course unviring the
neural network
so neurons are not able to communicate
anymore
however again neurons are not the only
cell type that are affected by dramatic
brain injury ultrasides also respond to
that and they become reactive
size change their identity they change
their shape and they lose the capacity
to perform some functions and they gain
new functionality
so this concept is very well described
in a recent publication by escorting at
all and natural Neuroscience where
authors try to Define summarize and
Define all uh about Airtel exercise so
if you are interested to know more about
this process I would recommend you to
read the paper
so in the result of this
process is happening in the brain of
course the brain functionality is
damaged what is interesting about
dramatic brain injury
is that it is resulting in long-term
cognitive impairment in 50 of cases
and this is telling us that something is
happening in hippocampus which is the
brain region responsible for cognitive
functions memory inflation
let me switch to the mouse model the
model that we study to understand change
in molecular changes in the brain after
dramatic brain injury so here you can
see a mouse and
a slice of a mouse brain taken from
Allen brain health
for the mouse brain here you see things
of of neurons there and you can see that
it is well separated into different
regions and these regions are well
defined
at the top we have the cortex
and usually in case of dramatic brain
injures it is the cortex which is
impacted first
however the cognitive impairment is also
related to the functions of hippocampus
this is the inner structure here you can
see hippocampus itself recognizable in
in the brain it has a very particular
neuronic structure
so uh what is happening uh in the case
of dramatic brain injury let me show you
the model that we use which is the
control vertical impact model
and here you can see the mice who is
undergoing a TPI surgery and during the
surgery the mouth head from the cortical
side is head
and you can compare here on this slide a
brain of a control mice with the brain
of the TPI mice and you can see that the
cortex the upper part of hippocampus is
highly impacted by DPI the tissue is
almost lost
hippocomposite cell doesn't suffer the
loss of tissue however when we put this
mice in a
condition to test their memory and how
well they can memorize
special information we see an impairment
of terminal dysfunction
here I would like to show you the
special memory test that you performed
and I think my colleague Pascal benefit
for
performing this experiment and
quantifying data so what we do we put
mouse in a water pool
and in that pool there is a hidden
platform
and
might repeatedly perform this function
they are in the pool they seem until
they will find the hidden platform and
they will rescue
so day by day mice are supposed to learn
the shortest path to the hidden platform
when we do these experiments with
control and TBI anymore five days
of experiments is showing that bottom is
improving their performance however
there is a significant difference
between the performance of DBI and
control life and TBI animals usually
memorize the location of the Hidden
platform
much worse than the control anymore they
need more time to find it
this is showing so special memory is
directly linked to the function of
hippocampus and this is indeed showing
that in this model although the
hippocampus itself didn't suffer the
loss of tissue in long term it is
leading to the laws of partial memory
let us go a little more into details and
understand the structure of hippocampus
and both is going wrong
uh What uh what is the reason of this
deficit deficit of memory
compost you can see a nice neurology
link and here I highlight the region of
dental gyrus
what is interesting about the original
tender jealous that it is a source of
stem cells in the brain it is one of the
positions where in adult brain we can
still find themselves
and they are located in this particular
Zone which I show by the arrow sub
granulation
so when we try schematically to present
what is the structure of this
subclinolog Zone here on the left you
can see by colors cells the dash young
progenitor or neural stem cells
and they are located residing in the
subgrant result
these cells are available to
differentiate two neurons and this part
of differentiation is well investigated
in adult months it is reported that in
the adulthood neurogenesis continues in
the examples and this is maintaining the
normal function of the brain
here you can see the developmental part
of neurons
so neural stem cells which are in yellow
color in this particular illustration
slowly they start developing developing
processes and
they generate mature neurons which
integrate to the molecular layer of a
compose and replace damaged
most curiously it is known that
astrocytes are sharing these progenitors
with neurons so they are differentiated
from the same neural stem cells then and
progenitor cells the path the
developmental part of our society is
less understood it is less studied it
and it is one of our goals to understand
how this does
mature and how effective is estrogenesis
in adult brain
so when looking into the literature and
reading the impacts about the impact of
TBI on Hippocampus PC reports that are
showing that in hippocampus the
neurogenesis is activated itself however
this new or neurons have a dramatic
morphological abnormalities
their shape is different and therefore
they are probably maladaptive to the
neurotic
and these are the course processes that
we need to understand to configure it
better so that newborn neurons would
integrate into the neural circuit and
assure normal functions
but confirm these reports in our hands
we did some extra experiments
here you can see the stainings that we
did in DPI and control mice by the dcx
marker which is a marker of young
neurons and progenitor cells
and on the right
[Music]
you can see the standings and the
quantification of it
so what we observe is that in total the
number of dcx cells is increasing in TBI
condition
and this increase is mostly dominated by
the cells that are inter-developmental
stages C and D you can see in this
illustration that the developmental
stages CNT are the points of
differentiation then small short
processes are already present however
these are not materials
so the question is why is the
neurogenesis blocked in this stage it is
locked in this statement we have only
short processes and it doesn't ever
next we looked also at astrocytes after
my undergo TPI surgery and gfap is a
marker of the active artery set
so when standing for this marker we saw
that on the side on the hemisphere of
the mouse brain
that we had the injury the default
expression is much higher which is
indicating about ongoing
[Music]
astrobiosis which is the process of
generation of reactive astrocyte so
anybody know that the young neural
progenitors and arthrocytes are affected
in hippocampus after cortical dramatic
brain injury and we want to understand
the consequences of that
so our first research question is to
understand how DPI is affecting
neurosemite progenitor cells at the
molecular layer and our second research
question is to understand how does that
type positioning alter in hippocampus
and the surrounding tissue after TPI
so answer to the first question we used
single cell whole transcription whole
transcript of sequencing
as I was describing in the beginning of
my talk so what we did
we took a sham controls and a DPI animal
the dissected 10 richest the region
where we expect neural stem and
projector cells to be located
be extracted with specific sorting of
these nsbc cells and put them into a
microtube
this is a workflow suggested by 10x
genomics and it is working very well
becoming the course
so pushing pulling this cells out of
dental generous and into the microtube
we are able to separate them one by one
extract their Emirates context
to sequencing
and get information about the whole
transcriptome of these steps
in my next slide I will show you our
results
so here is uh here in this slide I'm
showing all the cell types that we were
able to identify in the brain based on
their marker chain expressions
and if you are not familiar with this
plot let me quickly introduce that to
you so here we have a Yuma plot where
each dot is a cell
and cells similar to each other are
making a cloud so each cloud is a cell
population
as you can see here we have found a
number of cells in dangerous
so there's
rehearsals like microclear or liquid
dendrocytes we have found neural cells
endothelial cells follicle standard set
progenitor cells but here in this
presentation I want to focus on the two
lineages
one representing the development of
astrocytes and the other presenting
development of neurons
here on this group you can see the
astrocytic limit in green color named A1
A2 A3 and E4 and the neuronal lineage
the blue color and one and two and three
and then four you can notice that both
these lineages are initiating from
neural stem cell and larger clear-like
populations
as it is expected because we know that
astrocytes and neurons are sharing for
genitives
so this is already very nice to see an
adult playing the whole developmental
part of exercise and neurons and their
initiation point from the same
population of a neural stem cell like
so here in this part we have all the
data put together both DPI and
controlled animals and when we look into
the original these cells you can see the
bar plot here where the red color is
representing the percentage of cells
coming from control animals and blue one
is representing percentage of cells
coming from TBI animal you can notice
that astrocytic lineage named a1a2
Adrian for A4 is suffering loss after
CPA exhausted TBI premature astrocytes
die or they change their identities
and what comes to neurons at least one
of the populations we saw a significant
increase in numbers after CPS and this
is the population N4
uh consistent with our previous
observations we indeed have an activated
neurogenesis and the second interesting
conservation that we make is that
astrogenesis is either suppressed or
astrocyte Diet after CPI
so now let me switch to the second
research question that we were trying to
tackle in this project and it is about
cell type positioning in the tissue in
the whole hippocampus and the
surrounding tissue and how does this
other ntbi condition
they couldn't extract this information
of course from the single cells of
Kryptonics database that we had because
there we are dissociating the tissue and
we are pushing sets out of the tissue so
we don't know from which exact special
locations they are coming
that's why we need to complement our
database with a special transcriptomics
so when it comes to special transatomic
Technologies 80s
about quantifying transcriptomes
of the cells
in the tissue without
touching the tissue itself
in here we have two possibilities
currently first one is to obtain the
whole transcriptome from a given side of
the tissue however the resolution of the
whole transcriptome Institute sequencing
technology is low and we cannot obtain
information about single cell so we know
that the transcriptome is collected from
a given location in the tissue but we
don't know if in that location the
responses to size probably or maybe the
gap between cells
so we are not very sure that every dot
is representing one cell and the second
set of technologies that are available
are allowing to quantify at a single
cell resolution
transcripts however the number of
transcripts is limited until recently it
was limited to 10 12 markers
however decent Technologies are allowing
to increase this number significantly
and our choice was to go for this
because we were interested in single
cell quantification of the transcripts
in the tissue
and uh thanks to PID the coach funding
we had access to the technology of
little fire Sciences before it was
commercialized
so this technology is allowing to stay
in hundred markers at the Single Cell
resolution at the same time in the
tissue
let me show you brain that you think so
we did our first paintings around 2
control and two DBI brain sections
and since we had the capacity of 100
teams we chose the financial expression
between NSP systems to identify to find
effective populations tissue survey
chose and SPC markers
next we chose mature astrocytic and
neuronal markers in order to see
what are the changes at the level of the
tissue
I will quickly show you our results
people are able to quantify these
transcriptor transcripts 100 transcripts
but the Single Cell resolution
and getting back to the expected picture
of
a young progenitors newest and
progenitor cells we indeed found them in
the subconscious zone of hippocampus and
here you can see our quantification so
dark blue dots are showing more NSC
neural stem cell-like populations yellow
cells are mature astrocytes or neurons
depending on the lineage and you can
notice that indeed blue cells are found
in subclavula zone astrocytes developed
towards Helios
and neurons developed towards granola
neuronal layer of temperature this
unexpected picture and it didn't change
from
control to tibia animals which means
partially this pattern was not impacted
by TPI patterns itself
going larger to the level of the whole
tissue
we were able to recapitulate the
neuronal structurals hippocampus
here you can see the hippopotamus
layering and on the side our clustering
analysis based on hundred marketing and
you can see that we have found neuronal
layers that are colored in various
colors here neurons and in the
surrounding zones
uh then we looked at the populations at
the hippocampal level so we don't have a
single cell Text data set representing
the same
frame of the brain however based on our
100 Market chains we saw very
interesting shifts after DPI here you
can see a comparison between control and
DBI anymore and in black dots you see a
population which is representing
reactive astrocytes and you can see that
in controlled animals this population is
missing violent DBI anymore we have a
very specific special pattern their
distance are found
this is very interesting when it is
showing that not all astrocytes become
the active they are responding to injury
to to specially
distinctly only a fraction of exercise
in very specific positions become
reactive
and the next observation that we have is
the distribution of neurons and for some
populations some neuronal populations
disorder Dropout of mature neuron
numbers in this particular case you can
see in the surrounding tissue of
hippocampus we have a Dropout of neurons
in the back condition we observe
clusters
um with this let me go to my conclusions
so I hope I could introduce you the
concept of single cell and spatial
transcriptomics and how this could be
used to study injury and disease I
showed you that neurogenesis intended
gyrus is impacted up to PPI
uh that these things exercise
progenitors have been found in our
analysis in dangerous and the number of
these younger societies dropping after
traumatic brain injury
uh I showed you a population of reactive
astrocytes which was occurring
especially located in especially very
locally in the size where the injury has
happened and finally I showed you that
the loose on neural populations in the
parts of the brain where we had
astrocity response
in the future we are going to make use
of our whole transcriptomes in the cell
database to identify molecular Pathways
that have been affected by TBI and to
understand what is going wrong with
neurogenesis and estrogenesis right
after the injury and secondly we are
going to enrich our special database in
order to understand the relationship
between neuronal loss and
the appearance of the active asteroid
with this I want to thank you all I want
to thank my colleagues who contributed
in this research
and our funding agencies for making it
possible
thank you very much for your attention